tom
is in moscow idaho hi tom how are you
i'm doing well thanks guys for taking my
call sure what's up
okay so i'm a little bit uh in chris's
words i'll blend them panicked and
pumped if you will
we've been blessed uh financially
and uh so i guess
i don't want to get rid of assets i want
to hang on to them for a legacy for my
children my children's children
if you will because land out here is
going to the roof
um and with the covet thing going on
there's just more people flooding in
here
so we have 143 acres we have five rental
homes
we still have a little bit of debt i did
divide up
some ground this year if i throw sold
off three lots
that would wipe our debt out 100 percent
um we do well financially uh we're one
of those everyday people
that you wouldn't know about so
do i sell off the land uh 20 acres of
143
or just keep doing what we're doing here
how much debt you got left
and how much income you got how long are
you going to be how long it's going to
take if you don't sell the land
wife and i are both 52 years old
we have 280 000 in debt yet one is on
our primary
there's another residence we used to
live in we kept as a rental and we have
another one on a rental so we have five
rental
homes we have about a maximize my
ira or correction by 401k
what's your household in 25
75 000 a year combined
[Music]
gonna take a while 385.
well yeah i guess you haven't met me yet
so well i do
i i met a thing called math well we have
we having a business as well
well i ask you what your income is
what's your income
i cannot depend upon my fluctuating
income
yes you can what i'm asking what your
freaking income is what is your income
70 it's not
you have a business on the side that you
haven't told me about
it varies dave i know so does mine
you can't depend upon my income it could
be 200 000
gross one year could be four hundred
thousand dollars just answering my
question what are you gonna make next
year off this business
it's it could be fifty thousand profit
it could be a hundred thousand
literally it could be twenty eight
million but it's not what do you think
you're really gonna make
let's say 50. that's what you really
think you're gonna make
that's your actual projection correct
what'd you make last year what'd you
make last year on it
i think on tax purposes probably about
uh 40 50. on paper okay all right
so you have a approximately depending on
the variable portion of your income 110
000
income how quick do you think you're
going to pay off 385 if you don't sell
off these lots
280 280 200 i'm sorry i'm sorry
well i'm putting 25 000 into my
401k do i stop that and throw everything
at it
okay as well the point is if you're
putting 15
of your income towards retirement which
is what you should be doing at baby step
four then how quick are you going to pay
off 280
with a 75 to 150 000
income we don't know exactly what it's
going to land it's going to take a while
now i personally would probably rather
hold the lots on the contiguous
20 acres to the 143 than i would a
rental
rentals i can replace i can't replace
somebody living next door to me that i
can't
buy back yeah yeah that's what i'm
sitting here thinking too tom
you know letting go of that rental uh it
allows you to keep the land it allows
you to wipe out the debt and now you're
able to move forward my friend yeah
uh and and that's the better plan and i
know you i could hear it in your voice
you like to buy and hold uh but in the
rentals right but
but that rental letting it go it's going
to allow you to pay off your primary
residence and you're holding the dirt
yep you you you that's the better
long-term play if you if you want to let
go of the dirt and trade it for the
rental that's fine but you're going to
make a trade here
yeah if you're smart i i would not sit
and try to cash flow my way out of this
i would move one of these assets off the
books and get rid of that
either i'd move the rentals or i'd move
the lots and you just get aside which
one you love
more um i personally would rather have
the property
contiguous to me and and ditch the
rentals and then come back and get
rentals
why is that because you can't get it
back that's right once it's gone that's
right
that's right and so um i i have
you know every property that i own i buy
property when it comes up adjacent to me
uh if i can
you know if it's reasonable people i got
you know sometimes people are crazy i'm
not paying overpaying but i'm just
saying
if i can pick up a property that's
adjacent to a property
i've got two lots adjacent to my home i
got six lots adjacent to my lake house
and for buffer right because i can't get
that back
and none of them produce income they're
there just because of the way he was
talking this idea of legacy this idea of
dirt and
you know and it goes up in value and
you're going to be okay with it it's
you're going to make money on it it's
just a matter of how much
and you're protecting your sanity by
keeping space
yeah so i it's up to you but i that's
you can look at it and work your way
through now if you really are gonna make
you know a hundred thousand on this
business instead of 50
and you're just sandbagging me because
you're trying to be conservative because
you can't end quote air quotes count on
this
income then you might want to just not
do either and take three years and knock
it out live on your
salaried income use all of your business
income and be done in three years
that's right if you could do that i
might do that yeah but if you're going
to be in debt
for uh seven or eight years more yeah
playing with it they're messing around
and that's what the numbers you're
giving us are indicating
uh then i wouldn't i'd sell the rentals
personally
and tom i want to invite you to hop over
to entreleadership.com
uh where we work with businesses and we
guide them
uh people that are self-employed people
that are leaders and managers
because we help them grow their business
grow their profits as well as their team
so hop over check out
entreeleadership.com it's gonna
give you the boost i'm telling you got a
lot of tools inside of there that can
help you in your business
yeah and you know it's a good idea to
just stop a second and say
um if the pandemic didn't teach you
folks this
here's a thing you should know you can't
count on any of your income
that's right i have a steady job
[Laughter]
that's a funny thing you know it because
we've proven this year there's no such
thing
no we really have and so you know i i'm
secure
no you're not you're secure is your
ability to save money
and go get another job now go go take
your skills to the marketplace and make
money with them
that's what makes you secure you're
you're not secure in your job so
your business income is never secure
because things happen
yeah we've learned that again this year
that's why we want to be the third pig
the one in the brick house so when the
pandemic wolf comes and he huffs and he
puffs and he blows
then he just gets out of breath because
we had an emergency fund
we were debt-free and you ain't going
nowhere i ain't going anywhere ain't
going nowhere
mr carnivore i'll be sitting here in my
house
8-4 and that's where you want to get to